hello everyone welcome back to the game
so it's stage at e3 2016 today Justin
hey old and I are joined by Harvey Smith
co-creative director on dishonour to our
came Studios Harvey thank you so much
for joining us thank you guys for having
me yeah what was it like being able to
reveal gameplay at the Bethesda shirt oh
my god such relief we you know we
announced Dishonored 2 at e3 last year
with the trailer with Emily in it
fighting [ __ ] work soldiers with Caryn
Jenn dosh and a mission called the
clockwork mansion and that was fantastic
the reception we got from hardcore fans
of dishonored and from new people was
great of course but everybody's been
saying when are you going to show us
gameplay when you're gonna show us
gameplay is there a new engine what's
going on what about Corvo you know we
have we have all these questions all the
time right and so we're just like
waiting and waiting and waiting and so
from my dear friend raphaël colantonio
and me and our art director sebastian
matome who helped with a lot of the
footage for that it's all in game it's
all missions you play in the game just
like huge outpouring of thanks for
everybody's response because we have
just been inundated by the positivity
from people who have now seen the game
and they're excited again so it's great
yeah and it showed up a lot of really
cool abilities but that time one in
particular I thought was really clever
oh thank you yeah you know other people
have touched upon similar mechanics
before but we really wanted our level
design team led by level design director
Christoph carry a and lead level
designer Joachim dahveed we worked very
closely with them and one of their big
ideas was pushing that mission and we
debated all kinds of things should you
have your powers like blink or devouring
swarm or should you have none of that
and just have the outsiders timepiece
and for those who missed what he's
talking about you don't have your
supernatural powers in this manner but
you can move back and forth in two
different time periods you can watch
people through the other time period
time passes and both of them
continuously regardless of where you're
at it's kind of mind-bending and it's
this it's this concept we had this time
let's do dishonor bigger and better new
protagonists all new powers new city we
can talk about any of those things if
you want but let's build the missions
around big interesting themes
so we have we've shown the clockwork
mansion where the walls floor and
ceiling move we've shown the dust
district which is hit by these periodic
random storms that change stealth and
visibility and another one of them is
the crack in the slab mission where you
can travel back and forth in two time
periods within the same house let's talk
a little bit about so if you played the
first game was Corvo obvious by the end
of the game you have a load of abilities
how do you kind of deal with like the
reset problem you know when you're
coming into this on and two is Corvo
still fully stacked with abilities or
you have to dial it back a bit for new
players well you know you can play Emily
if you want to have the new experience
right all of our powers are new and she
starts out just as the Empress and
builds up from there the outsider offers
her his mark but Corvo is a different
situation if you want the nostalgic
dishonored experience you play korbo and
how we handle the fact that he had all
the powers you chose before and you
could is maybe a bit of a spoiler but
all I can say is that we handle it and
you get to see the outsider again and
his interaction with Corvo is a little
different than his interaction with
Emily and you know we talked a little
bit about that you're the first person
who's actually asked that question and
you see pretty quickly in the game how
we resolve that how we handle that but
one thing that's brand new that we just
started talking about yesterday morning
I don't think most people have heard
about it is that there's another way to
play the game this time when you meet
the outsider early on in the game and he
offers you his mark which is how you get
supernatural powers you can say no so
this is your secret third path yeah you
can you can literally tell him I've had
enough of your gifts I don't want
anything more from you and so you can
play the entire game without blink
without possession without any
supernatural powers whatsoever you we
call it con flesh and steel mode there
was an achievement we did last time
called flesh and steel or only flesh and
seal but it I can tell you it
dramatically changes the game it's a lot
harder personally I like playing with
the powers but once in a while I do a
playthrough with no powers and it's
leaning sneaking hiding crouching under
things climbing up on top of buildings
the game is much more vertical this time
karnatka is a place with giant windmills
and wind powered security devices so you
can get on the rooftops much more but
doing all of that is possible without
supernatural powers it's just a little
harder and so it really you get this
game you can play as Emily with all our
new powers in place Corvo you can
slaughter a bunch of people or you can
literally not engage in violence as you
play you can play the entire game
without killing anyone and you also
could experiment with no powers mode
which really makes it a different
experience it's really cool that you you
have Emily who's a strong female
character was was there any pushback
from from anybody higher up saying maybe
this isn't a good we want a strong male
protagonist because that's what sells uh
no I mean people were pretty excited
about Emily like I think early on when I
pitched it maybe someone at the company
thought that I meant the 10 year old
girl they were like wait a second you
know but as soon as I explained like no
no we're talking about grown-up empress
Emily who has her pillars are done wall
empress and assassin right so she's got
she's stylish and she's not just a
female Corvo you know she has her own
personality and I think we avoided all
the traps that people fall into often
when they have a female protagonist our
narrative designer is sashka Duvall I
worked very closely with her in lyon
france and you know she was a huge fan
of the first game who came in to help us
make the second game and was early on it
was our special project to like make
sure we handle Emily exactly right we're
very closely with the art directors and
the art team to get her costume right to
get a body right to get her moves right
you know it's subtle details right there
was a scene early in the game where
someone attacks her before she's a
supernatural badass right and she fights
back and early on there was a scene
where somebody animated her to slap the
guy and then he punches her and we were
just like no no no no no Emily punches
this guy and he feels it it's a it's a
good punch and then he had sir about you
know so it's it's details like that
right if this is a character you want to
be she has to be a badass she has to be
aspirational you know so she has to be
that from the very beginning she can't
just have the
magical thing happened to her then
become right there's got to be a kernel
of strength there to begin with you know
I think from my when I play dishonored
the the setting of dunwall just I mean I
live in London so obviously and I've
spent time in Edinburgh all of these
themes coming together to make a truly
unforgettable city but we're moving out
of dunwall in Tucson it too right yeah
the game starts and ends in dunwall but
we spend most of it down in Karnataka
which is like the southern edge of our
Empire so we call it the jewel of the
south but now it's kind of a rotting
place and the vegetation is different
the light in the sky is different the
industry is different there the songs
the the culture you know it's it's a
different place but because we include
done wall and car acha in the same game
you get the contrast between the two of
them just like the darkness on the light
but both is still pretty dog uh you know
dunwall is like you said it's it's
London and edinboro it's grey it's
pointed roofs it's it's brick and kanaka
is much more like Spain Italy a little
bit of grease it's just that currently
it's crushed under the boot of a guy
called the Duke of cercanos Duke Luka a
bell and it's a place that's going
through a troubled time I think is the
best way to put it yeah and thinking
about the abilities that you have that
that Emily does have kind of a new set
that's a different way to play the game
where did you come up with the ideas for
that well you know what are they things
you want to do include in the first game
and maybe now you get a chance to try
them out no those are all new concepts
and our game design team we work very
closely with them to pitch a bunch of
ideas prototype a bunch of stuff cut the
ones it didn't work and then even like
even toward the end when we had the set
of powers uh yo on our technical artist
came to us one day and he was like hey I
have an idea for a power and he pitched
it and it ended up being after the game
design team massaged it a bit it ended
up being Domino you know so we pulled
the team we talked to people we all
talked about playing dishonored and what
we would have liked to been able to do
and then we put it through some filters
right does this feel like appropriate to
the game it's it's a game about courtly
intrigue and then running through Grammy
alleys and it's not a game about like
taking pleasure in killing or whatever
it's it's a game about political
assassination and
fighting for your life and so there are
some powers that really fit well in that
environment and our big philosophies are
about exploration which means you can
play at your pace you're not just
following someone else's scripted linear
path you're exploring you're finding
your own way in many different ways
geographically but also in terms of your
approach your style but it's not just
exploration it's improvisation right and
so the way we do powers you can actually
combine them in ways that we didn't plan
before so there's a scene where a a
group of religious fanatics is about to
there they have a firing squad they're
about to put down some heretics and our
lead designer dingo Picabo was playing
and he wanted to do something different
for the guy that he was demonstrating
the game too and so instead of doing
what he normally does which is like use
far reach to yank the the guy with a
pistol out of the scene he he had this
flash of inspiration and he dominoed the
guy with a pistol and the victim
together and so when the guy with the
pistol pulled the trigger it killed both
of them because when you use Emily's
domino power you link people and they
share the same fate and so it was just
like this flash of inspiration and a
cool move and poetic justice in a way so
you said the just wanted one and two are
being bridged by a novel in a series of
comics are they you know key dude you
need to be able to read those who didn't
also know too is there going to be a way
i remember i believe mass effect when
mass effect went onto ps3 you could sort
of there was an interactive comic that
they put in the game are you planning
anything like that well i would say that
bridging dishonored one and dishonour to
15 years pass our alt victorian world
roughly takes place 1837 and dishonored
one those that's the year that spring
hill Jack was cited this guy with a kind
of a demon mask and boots jumping from
building to building and so imagining
Corvo is the guy who sprung or you know
who inspired that legend that that's
kind of what we were thinking I never
anticipated a Spring Heeled Jack right
there you go I know I very rarely talk
to journalists who recognize that
reference so I had a podcast
recommendations via great okay all sort
of like that but 1837 the first game so
the next game is like
you know 15 years after that and the dlc
with dowd bridges some of the gap
because some of the some of the plot
elements from one feed into the eventual
you know the dishonor to and that's
where we experimented with a voiced
protagonist which emily has voice Corvo
has a voice in the new game but then
also the comics take place just before I
thank the new game and the novel takes
place like three years before the new
game I think so i would say the game
dishonored one this one or two anyone
can approach it right it works just if
you walk into it it's an exotic fantasy
world with stealth and first-person
combat and supernatural powers but if
you know all of that stuff like you've
read the comics and you've read the
novels and you've played the DLC I would
say you have a very rich experience in
that in that circumstance you said that
I remember in the presentation you said
that every alley everything has to tell
a story that's our goal that's the goal
yeah how do you I mean a lot of players
these days maybe they don't appreciate
things like that is deeply I've you have
you done ways to sort of signposts you
know like you should be looking at this
haha no we find that our approach to
making games is to pack way more into
the game then you can see in one
playthrough so you'll only see like 15
or you know you'll only see like less
than fifty percent in one pass but we
think everybody will see something
awesome javi thank you so much for
joining us for more on III 2016 make
sure you keep your eyes peeled to
gamespot com thank you